BILLY RUTLEDGE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Billy Rutledge from
the AOI team at Google.
And we're here today at
CES in the NXP Pavilion
to introduce our new
product-- the Edge TPU Dev
Board that features our edge TPU
chip combined with the NXP iMX
8 SoC as a kit for
developers to experiment
with artificial intelligence
for the first time.
So the board itself is
actually two pieces.
It's the base board here,
which has all the connectors
that most developers would
use to prototype a new product
idea.
And then the SoM module--
SoM-- includes the
CPU, GPU, and TPU chip,
as well as the memory
and Wi-Fi and Bluetooth.
And it actually snaps
into the baseboard
using high-density connectors.
And so that allows
you to experiment
with the actual hardware
in a development setting,
but be able to buy the SoM
part for production line
when you're ready to
take your smart speaker,
smart dishwasher, smart TV to
a scalable production plan.
So today we're showcasing
a few different demos
of how you might experiment
with this type of technology,
and hoping to inspire people to
explore using AI on the edge.
PETER MALKIN: Hi, my
name is Peter Malkin.
I work for Google.
I'm a software tech
lead for AOI projects.
And today we're showing you
a demo of facial detection
that runs on Edge TPU.
The key point about Edge TPU
is the privacy and security.
From now on, your
pixels do not need
to travel to a data center.
You do not need to contribute
your data to any company.
You can run all your machine
learning inference locally
on the chipset.
In this case in
particular, we've
tried a network that can
recognize human face.
And it's running
locally on device
on a small embedded
system that runs Linux.
JUNE TATE-GANS: Hi, my
name is June Tate-gans.
I'm actually one of
the software engineers
working on AOI projects.
One of our demos here at CES
is actually a teachable machine
where we actually
use local inference
to train a model directly on
the device with no network
connectivity.
We call this our
teachable machine demo,
and it's right here.
And essentially it has a
camera pointing up at the sky.
Now the first thing
I have to do is
train it to teach it about
what the background is
so it can differentiate
between the objects
I'm about to show it and
what the background is.
And the first thing I do is
I press one of these buttons
to actually tell it
what it's looking at.
So now it knows what
the background is.
I can now train it on an object.
In this particular case, I'm
gonna use this ice cream.
So hold the ice cream
over, press the button.
It now can differentiate between
background and ice cream.
And you know it's machine
learning and doing inference
because I can show
it a different color
and get the same
result. And this
can be extended to other objects
as well, such as this hot dog.
So hot dog, ice
cream, hot dog again.
And the same thing with a donut.
So donut, hot dog,
and ice cream.
LEONID LOBACHEV: Hello.
My name is Leonid.
I work for Google
for AOI project.
And I will talk about our
[INAUDIBLE] demo here.
So if you notice that under
each of the bigger demos,
we have a small display
underneath with a depth camera.
And it shows the time.
And that's important
characteristic
because it tracks how much
time people spend looking
at the other bigger demos.
And you can notice that we
display the bounding boxes
around the people's faces.
So here is my face.
And there is a green
box showing that I'm
looking toward the demo stand.
And if I turn away,
like right now you
can probably see the red box.
I'm not sure myself, but
it should have been red.
And this has been run totally
on the development board.
You can notice that,
behind the display,
we have the same words like
[INAUDIBLE] demos here.
So there is no internet or
cloud connection required.
And that's a good application
because we are ourselves
interest at home many people are
looking at other bigger demos.
And you can notice
like, in the middle,
we have something like 4
and 1/2 hours right now.
And in the corner stand there
is like slightly more than three
hours.
It's quite explainable,
but still interesting,
statistics together.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: So
we're just beginning
to scratch the surface
of what's possible with
artificial intelligence today.
And we're excited to offer
the Google Edge TPU Dev
Kit for the world to experiment
with on-device AI specifically
to explore the capabilities
with high performance on device,
security with having all the
data on the board itself,
and performance by being able
to process everything locally
on the machine.
We think it will open up
a world of opportunities
for new product development.
We're excited to see what
you might build with it next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]